Alex hosi when we did our episode at the
start of this year we used a clip from
it at the very start and it got to a bit
of bother because we put it on Instagram
and taken out of context people were
quite unhappy and he posted basically
kind of a press release a rebuttal
against it this is what it is if you had
disadvantages I agree with you you are
right it's harder to be successful if x
happened to you replace x with gender
race birth deformity different language
different country abuse Etc the main
point is that despite the advantage you
only have one choice what you're going
to do about it number one take action
anyway and become proof to other people
like you also born into or abused into
this tragedy that you were that they too
can overcome it number two blame and
complain do whatever you want I support
your choice but only one of those
decisions will make you better if you
had tough happened to you it sucks and
it's not your fault but now what my two
cents win anyways and prove that you can
win even when the chips are stacked
against you and you're dealt a lousy
hand